um  Kevin headed it's it's an Achilles  injury I don't know the extent of it  he'll have an MRI tomorrow prior to  coming back he went through four weeks  with our medical team and was thorough  and those experts and multiple MRIs and  multiple doctors and we felt good about  the process he was cleared to play  tonight that was a collaborative  decision I don't believe there's anybody  to blame but I understand is this world  and if you have to you can blame me I  ran our best ball turret operations  department and they tell you something  about Kevin Durant Kevin Durant loves to  play basketball and the people that  questioned whether he wanted to get back  to this team were wrong and I'm not here  to he's one of them he's one of the most  misunderstood people he's a good  teammate a good person it's not fair